ANDY CHANG: Hi, everyone.
So what we're going
to talk about today
is really the process of
moving from your secure,
on-premise to hybrid
and then into cloud.
I think, as you've
heard throughout Next,
at Google, we're invested in
trying to reduce the obstacles,
the concerns that you
don't need to have
to accelerate and elevate
the way you do development
so that you can grow businesses,
grow your applications,
and be successful.
Especially in security,
what we're talking about,
as George pointed out, is cloud
should be the immune system
for you to protect you against
cyber attacks-- something you
don't have to actively
manage, something
that, in fact, is
there in the background
always defending you.
Now, we recognize
that not all of you
are in the same space
in terms of moving
to the third generation cloud.
Many of you have
on-premise facilities,
have needs to have
workloads that
are both in and
on-premise situation
as well as in the cloud.
And really, the key is
to for us to give you
the controls to allow you
to manage the trust the way
you need.
As Neal has pointed out, beyond
just the underlying security
and trust built into our
core platform beneath Google,
we need to continuously
provide you
the controls to access
those capabilities so you
can secure your workloads
the way you need them to be.
So at the core of what we're
talking about at Google,
the security is really based
on four key principles--
trust and transparency,
control, audit compliance,
and innovation.
And what we mean by this is
it's not just sufficient for us
to have superior technology.
Trust that you have
in us and what we do
is really built in being
transparent about things.
And that's part of Neil's
talk earlier today,
is one of the steps to get you
a sense of what really goes on
behind the scenes.
In addition, for control from
enterprises and businesses,
you need the ability to have
access to the capabilities
to configure and
run your business
and control the user service
data access levels as you need.
For audit and compliance,
our commitment
is to make sure
that, in addition
to the certifications
that we have on our cloud,
we're going to be
able to support
you to get the
certifications that you
need to run your businesses.
And of course, we're
focused on innovation,
whether it's the machine
learning that Jeff talked
about, essentially the
superpower of having
cloud machine learning added
to your capabilities-- really,
the ability to have you focus on
your business, and then for us
to take care of the rest.
So for today's talk, we're
going to focus, however,
on folks who are not yet
in the generation 3 cloud.
And the common questions
we get in security
really fall into
five main categories.
How do you manage identity
and access control
so that the policies which
you already have today
can be reflected in the
cloud that you move to?
Network security-- how do you
create the isolation and trust
zones that you need to segregate
your users an information
as you might like?
Data protection-- how is
your data, your user's data,
your customer's data protected,
and how do you control that?
Threats and vulnerabilities--
how really access
to and breaches and
intrusions are handled so
that you are protected upfront.
And ultimately, audit
logging-- the things
that allow you to know what's
going on in your systems
to know every action.
So in order to do
this, we're going
to use an example to
walk you through a step
by step process of migrating
from an on-premise application
to a hybrid situation where part
the application runs in cloud,
and then finally, to
a full GCP instance.
Now, to do this,
we tried to pick
a small representative
example application.
So we've created a
Memegen application
which is built on a LAMP stack.
It has a MySQL database
and an Apache front end.
And basically, it allows
you to start out on premise,
and it will move it
step by step forward.
So let's go.
So the first step,
as we talked about,
was taking your existing
identities and your policies,
and how does that
come with you in cloud
so you don't have to
change and do other things.
So to help me talk
through that, I'm
going to invite
Ameet Jani, who's
the product manager
for Identity for Cloud,
to walk you through
identity federation.
Thank you.
AMEET JANI: Thank you, Andy.
Your voice.
So Andy and I were walking
through a potential scenario
here, and we thought it
would be kind of fun-- fun
being relative, last day of
a conference kind of fun,
I guess-- to walk through
an actual customer
type of example,
to really represent
what our customers go through.
Andy and I have talked
to a lot of customers,
and we're hearing--
we thought it
would be fun to walk through
what that would look like.
So one of things we thought
we should walk you through
is the typical
scenario of a customer.
You already have an
identity provider.
You already have a source
of truth for your identities
where you've defined
users and groups.
And what you really want is
just to carry that with you
into the cloud.
And so what you're going to
see-- let's do exactly that.
We're going to use an IDP.
We can talk to It.
Insert your name of
your identity provider
here, whether it's Active
Directory or anybody else.
And we're going to federate
your users in groups to Google.
And then the next thing
that we're going to do
is show you how those now exist.
They're federated.
All you have to do is assign
permissions to your groups,
and everybody is there.
And then lastly, I
think just to prove
that this is a federated
identity use case,
we're going to delete a user
in your identity provider
and show you how
quickly that reflects.
So just to highlight what
we talked about here,
you'll see these very
complicated art graphics here.
You'll see the non-Google
identity provider.
Your identity is
your source of truth.
It gets federated
to Google, and then
you just assign the
users that are there.
So why don't we
jump into the demo?
Andy is going to
drive it for us here.
You'll see this is
our identity provider.
In this case, we used Ping.
You can use any identity
provider that you like.
Most of them come with a
Google connector, as Ping does.
And so the idea
is, then, that you
connect Ping to your
Google environment,
and your source of
truth is now connected.
So here you'll see, in this
very simplified example,
we have users that
are assigned here.
And each of these users are
already assigned to a group.
And so Andy will show you
here that these groups exist.
And I think the key
he wants to focus on
are the network administrator,
the network viewer,
and the security administrator.
These are the sample types
of groups that we've created.
And the users that we've
talked about earlier, which
were Bob, Amy, and
AJ, who are assigned
to each of these groups.
And we'll see how that carries
over when you get into cloud.
So then once you
federate it-- here's
an example of that group--
once those users and groups are
federated, you'll be able
to come to your Google
Console, which Andy
will do now, and you'll
be able to see both of those.
Just to prove that it
has, in fact, federated,
when you make a change in
your identity provider,
the users show up here.
So here you'll see Bob, AJ, and
of course, Amy reflected here.
And they're already
assigned to those groups,
because the groups have also
been federated with you.
So as you click into
AJ, for example,
you'll be able to
see he's already
a member of this group-- in this
case, the network viewer group.
And the same will
be true for Bob,
and the same will be true for
Amy as well in this example.
Just to quickly
touch on those rules,
the rules are network
viewer is obviously
a read-only kind of role.
A network admin is somebody
who can create new network
and take networking
type functionality.
And a security admin, our
hero of the story here,
is the one who can do security
actions but not necessarily
network actions.
So then why don't we
jump into the IAM window?
So those of you
who are familiar,
you come into the
cloud console, you'll
see Andy has already
created those--
the groups are already there.
They pre-populate
when you do a search
or when you create a new member.
And he's assigned
them to groups.
So here you can see
the roles are already
assigned-- compute
network admin,
compute network viewer, and of
course, compute security admin.
So those are predefined roles
that already exist within IAM,
and you can just assign
them to the group.
Note here we didn't
assign a single user
to a role that automatically
gets inherited when you
become a member of that group.
So we've done a setup here.
Why don't we actually live a day
in the life of-- let's pretend
we're Amy.
Amy was the security
administrator.
So Amy comes in.
She logs into her single
sign on system here.
And then she should
get redirected directly
into the Google console,
the Google Cloud Console.
Or not.
Just as a show of hands, how
many of you are using Ping?
Just out of curiosity.
Trying to understand.
OK.
I'm guessing most of you
are Active Directory.
That's what I figured.
Are there others of
note that we should--
you can scream them out.
AUDIENCE: Google.
AMEET JANI: Google, OK.
So here you see can
see Amy is logged in.
You can see that she's
in fact logged in.
Because she's a
security administrators,
she really has no business
going through common dashboards
and GAE screens and GCE screens.
So we'll jump into the
Networking screen here.
Remember, she's a
security administrator.
So when we come to
Networks as the option,
you'll see she cannot,
in fact, create networks.
She can't do firewalls.
She can't do VPNs.
She can't do routers
and things like that.
But in fact, when she
goes into firewalls,
she should be able to create
a firewall-- she is a security
administrator-- and
take the action there.
So again, she's already
been assigned the role
without having to
explicitly do that.
If we were to do the same
for Bob, for example--
we can come in and
be Bob for a moment--
you can see, in this
case, that's me.
There we are, Bob.
Again, Bob is a
network administrator,
so no need to be in
any common screen here.
But if you jump
into the networking,
you'll find what you expect--
that Bob can, in fact, create
networks, can create VPNs,
can create DNS load balancers.
But when you take it to the
firewall rules, of course,
he's unable to do
anything there.
And then we can do the
same for AJ as well.
AJ, again, had a
viewer role, so we'd
have-- we'll let Andy you
jump into the-- here we go.
So then we can jump into
the Networking itself.
And you'll find, in fact,
only read only screens.
It can only take
viewership, but can't
do any actions
themselves, as expected.
No rocket science here.
So I think that's the high level
overview of the identity sync.
Today, most commercial
and almost all open
source identity providers
have a natural bridge
into Google Apps and Google,
so that should naturally work.
But let's walk
through an example.
We talked about concluding here
with showing True Federation.
So why don't we delete AJ?
And then when you go into Admin,
Console, and do a refresh,
you'll find that AJ--
fingers crossed-- will
have disappeared from all this.
There you go.
AJ is no longer there.
So it's a live system.
It happens instantaneously.
So you don't have to-- the
minute somebody decides
to go on to better
opportunities and are
no longer at your
company, you're
able to remove them from
your identity provider,
and they completely get shut
down from access to the Cloud
Console.
So that's the
high-level summary here.
Andy, why don't I
transition it back to you?
ANDY CHANG: Thanks.
So lesson number
1 from migrating
from your on-premise situation
to either a hybrid or cloud
is that you, in fact, can
bring your identities.
You don't need to recreate them.
You're able to federate and
use the existing privileges
and IEM to enforce them.
So the next thing we're going to
talk about is the hybrid cloud.
And so what do we mean
by the hybrid cloud?
So today, what we're
going to talk to you about
is first from the Memegen app
in the on-premise situation.
And you probably can't see
it, but this is actually
the on-premise server.
So if we go to that
on-premise server,
this is the Memegen
app for that server.
And it's a little,
tiny on-premise server.
It's live.
The other thing we'll
talk about is the project
that we just showed you
the controls and IEM for.
So it's the Memegen
Next 16 application.
And today, we have a front end.
So we've split it
now so that we're
going to keep the
back end on the server
and have the front
end show up in cloud.
So this is the front end,
the instance PHP piece.
And right now, though, if I
go to that one, that website,
you notice it's not
connecting to anything.
Because we actually
haven't created a VPN,
a trusted connection
between the two.
So we're going to fix that.
So what we're going to do now
is leverage the networking
that we just talked
about before.
So I'm logged in as Kanji.
And Kanji, if you
might remember,
is one of the other
roles that I've created.
It has both network
permissions and also has
security permissions.
So as someone who has network
permissions and security
permissions, he's
able to basically go,
as we said before,
not do anything
with the main dashboard, but he
can create both networks, VPNs,
and routes.
So we're going to create a VPN.
So currently, there's a VPN.
We're going to connect
the front piece, which was
the instance, to the back end.
And we're going to use the
subnetwork that's created,
leveraging the subnet
technology we have.
It's in the US central region.
And we create a
static IP address
so we can do the VPN
connection, so we'll use that.
Now, on the other side, we need
a similar static IP address,
which we've locked in for
the on premise example.
It's IKEV2, and we need
to share its secret.
Now, I would not recommend
this shared secret,
because it's a
little bit simple.
But for the purposes
of this demonstration,
we're going to go
ahead and use that.
So now we have to use the local
connections here, and then
connect to the subnet.
Now, for the sake
of this demo, we're
showing this through menus.
But in fact, you can
have run G Cloud in RSDK,
so the same commands
can be scripted.
Or if you're running purely
in the services mode,
we give you the APIs to
allow you to run this, too.
So at scale, instead of
in this simple example,
you would be doing
this with automation.
So let's go ahead
and create this VPN.
So now it's going to take a
little bit of time for the VPN
to load.
So while we're doing this, we'll
talk about what's going on.
So as we said before, from
the on-premise server,
we have the MySQL database, and
we're connecting to a front end
instance.
Each of the VMs has its
own individual firewall,
so we had to set up the
details for the firewall.
And we'll show that
in a little bit on.
The web application
is on the front end.
Now, each of the
individual identities
has different control
over the settings--
the ability to either control
the VPN, the firewall,
and the underlying pieces.
So what we're taking
advantage of here
is really several things in
the features on our network.
The ability to create
private IP spaces
so that when you connect to
us, you're no longer traveling
on the open internet.
You're traveling within
our private network,
and your traffic stays
on our private network
encrypted as it moves forward.
In addition, we're taking
advantage of the ability
to have subnetworks, the
ability to really lock in
and segment your
trust the way you
need to based on how you want
to control the connections
and access between roles.
And finally, we're taking
advantage of the VPN.
So you notice now that the
VPN connection is green.
So we're going to
go back and see
if we can hit that same
node before and see
if it's connected.
And so we are.
We're now connected, and we're
on our way to full cloud.
So basically, we have the
database, the MySQL database
connected on the back end.
We have the PHP front
end serving up traffic.
So one of the steps
to the way there,
using our network and our
[INAUDIBLE] capabilities
to allow us to get there.
So lesson number 2-- you can
create the zones of trust
that you need by leveraging
the capabilities in the network
that we've talked about.
In addition, one of
the opportunities
when you have the
front end now on GCP
is to also leverage
the load balancing
that you heard about yesterday
in the networking talk, which
gives you both performance,
scaling, and also
an amount of DDOS
protection built in.
So the next thing that
we're talking about
is going the full GCP.
So going back again
to the underlying--
so going back again from a role
standpoint to an owner role,
I can take a look at
again the overall project.
And when we go look at
the overall project,
we have-- in addition to
the front end that we just
triggered, which is
this one, we also
have the ability to go back
and look at the full LAMP stack
version.
So what we've done is set up
a full LAMP stack version.
We've migrated everything over.
The other thing, if you
guys were paying attention,
when I showed you each
of the first two--
the on premise one and
also the hybrid one--
those were actually
only in HTTP.
So at Google, obviously,
we're big fans
and implement TLS and SSH.
So this is actually a full HTTPS
connection on our Google Cloud
platform implementing the MySQL
database as well as the PHP
front end.
Now, once you get
fully on our cloud,
the question is you have
now moved your data here,
but how do we connect
and continue to connect
so that you can do this fast.
So we have a large number
of different ways for you
to migrate your data
onto our cloud--
through VPN, through
direct peering,
through internetworking.
In addition, once your
data is in our cloud,
really the question is
how do we protect it.
So we really give
you three options
of how to protect your data.
First, by default,
your data is encrypted.
And it's actually
encrypted three ways.
The underlying data is
first charted and chunked.
Then each of those
pieces are encrypted.
The chunk key is then
encrypted, and a wrapping key
around the chunk
key is encrypted.
And those are then stored in
a key store, which manages
and rotates them as necessary.
Or if you want to encrypt your
data before you give it to us,
you certainly have that option.
You have full
control in that case.
Finally, you can give
us customer supply keys,
and then we can go ahead
and encrypt things for you
without us being able to
actually look at your data.
Additionally, yesterday
I think we talked to you
about audit logging.
So what we're going to show
you is-- this is a screenshot.
We're going to show you the live
logs, again, off of this GCP
instance.
So what we're seeing here
now is the events that
created after the firewall.
We can look at the events that
created off the Meme network,
which a the subnetwork.
And all of those things
are accessible to you
both in the activity stream.
You can search on them.
We can filter out
purely on activity.
We can filter out on looking
at a range of resources
within all the resources
within compute.
And if you look at all
the different resources,
the choices allow you
to look at a wide range
of both packets, changes in IEM,
permissions, and other pieces.
So finally, when you think
about going onto a platform,
it's important that
the underlying platform
has the governance and
the compliance pieces
that you need in case you need
to run those for your business.
So the Google Cloud platform is
regularly certified for SOC 2
and SOC 3, ISO 27001,
and then PCI DSS 30.
And we're engaged
in supporting you
to get the end-to-end
certifications as you
run your business partially
on our cloud as well
as the other pieces that you're
running in your own business.
So lesson number 3-- once you
are comfortable with bringing
the data onto our
cloud, you're then
fully encrypted by default,
and you're in TLS everywhere.
But this is really
just getting you
to where you are now moved
from on-premise to a cloud
environment, but you're
still, at this point,
using the cloud in a
way similar to how you
have before in your on-premise.
As we've talked about
throughout Next, what we really
want you to be
able to do is focus
on building great apps
and great businesses
and let us take care
of the operations
and really live in a
serverless environment.
So since we've been
talking about security,
another thing you
may have noticed
is we talked about LAMP
stack, but it's all in PHP,
so how do you deal with that.
So PHP has a range of
security vulnerabilities
that people try to exploit.
And part of that, then, is for
us to implement, as we have,
automated scanning for you.
So if you bring your
applications to our App Engine
product, we have a general
availability cloud security
scanner.
It's a website
scanner that basically
finds some of the most common
vulnerabilities proactively
before you deploy.
An example here is if you
look at the OWASP top 10--
injection, cross-site
scripting, components
with known vulnerabilities,
those are all very
common things that occur in
web apps and cause breaches.
So our security scanner
detects cross-site scripting,
mixed content,
insecure libraries.
And in 2016, we'll be
rolling out in addition
to SQL injection
and also the ability
to scan applications on GCE
and other installations.
In addition, we'll be
able to tie user features
around notifications
for you and the ability
to automate those scans.
So now we're going to show
you a little bit actually
how the scanner works.
So what we have here
is an application,
which we call Firing Range.
We open sourced that
a couple years ago.
It is the basis on which most
web vulnerability scanners test
against to make sure
they find sources
of cross-site scripting, mixed
content, and library pieces.
So what we're going
to do is show you
what one of these scan
results look like.
So in this project,
we have an application
called Public Firing Range.
If you're in App Engine, you
get a tab that's specifically
Security Scans, and
then you're able to look
at a range of scan results.
So if we look at the scans
that we ran last night,
it hit 657 URLs
in the application
and over 600 vulnerabilities.
And those vulnerabilities range
from cross-site scripting,
420 of them, and old
library, mixed content.
So for example, the
particular application
uses jQuery that's out of date.
So that would be an
immediate flag and something
you could fix.
In addition, we have in detail
for the cross-site scripting
errors the ability
for you to drill down
into each of these
errors, and in fact, both
replicate it to find
out where it actually
occurs in your code,
fix it, remediate it.
And this is all in
development before you
deploy to production.
So it catches things before
they actually hit production.
Currently, what we've seen
with folks who have used
the security
scanner is that when
it's a cross-site scripting
error, once identified,
80% of the users go back and
in fact fix it and remediate.
So that's a large number of
potential vulnerabilities
that have been eliminated
before any of the code hits
production.
So the lesson, really,
then is continue
to move to higher
levels of abstraction.
Abstraction and automation
are your friends.
And we provide you the
ability to leverage that today
through App Engine, through
BigQuery, and through Dataflow
so that you're really living the
serverless, no operations mode.
And that becomes the
next step of what
you can do once you've
gone from on premise
to hybrid to GC and then to the
true third generation cloud.
So finally, what's
next after this?
In recap, what we've talked
about is identity federation--
the ability for you,
when you already
have in place installs,
to take those with you,
for you not to have
to recreate them,
and for us to basically
respect them, enforce the roles
and access policies
that you had.
In addition, we talked
about the network security
needed to isolate
and create the trust
zones that you have through
VPN, through the subnetworking.
We talked about the
data protection,
the built-in encryption
as well as the control
that you have to further
encrypt and protect your data.
And then we talked
about the logging
and then the abstractions
and automation.
So ultimately, what's
next after this?
From a cloud security
side, those of you
who have done some of the code
labs, the specific details
of how we built each of these
pieces, which we couldn't get
into today on stage,
you can actually
walk through each
step in the code lab.
In addition, the cloud security
scanner highly recommend that
you guys try it out--
its ability to find
vulnerabilities, its
ability to be very,
very low noise and high signal
so that you can remediate .
directly.
And then on the app
side, once it's on GAE,
there's a couple
different options.
We talked about going
to App Engine directly
or to App Engine
Manage VMs, where
you can bring your own
programming system that you're
more comfortable and
familiar with-- moving
the MySQL to Cloud
SQL, and particularly
for this application,
which is image centric,
to take advantage of the machine
vision APIs that we have.
So with that, again,
for us, the ability
to go for a third
generation cloud
is really the ability to
combine security and innovation
and build what's next.
So thank you guys,
and both Ameet
and myself will be around
if you have any questions.
[APPLAUSE]